here in Arizona about this state's
response to the rising number of
coronavirus faces
to share a few reflections on what we've
heard and what we're determined to do
but before that let me take a moment to
reflect on another aspect of this day a
huge win for the people of Arizona for
American workers farmers and ranchers
and that is that as of today the u.s.
MCA has taken effect it is I am told in
this this state in particular a cease
trade with Mexico and Canada support 228
thousand jobs 20 billion dollars
annually and I want to take this
opportunity particularly to thank
Governor Doug Ducey for his efforts in
moving the USMC a letter to Congress
it's a candidate president Trump
committed to renegotiate NAFTA in a way
that put American jobs American workers
farmers and ranchers first we've done
that and that promise was kept when the
US MCA took effective
you have our sincerest
president Trump asked us to be here
today
with a dramatic rise of coronavirus
cases in Arizona to receive a briefing
introduced he and the healthcare team
about this state response
I want to say first and foremost to
Governor Ducey that in the very first
days of this pandemic your leadership
and your entire team in Arizona's really
formed a seamless partnership with our
administration with the White House for
a virus task force
and up until roughly three weeks ago
Arizona had literally set the pace
it's slowing the spread and flattening
the curve and we're grateful to you to
your team and to all the people of
Arizona for all of their efforts over
the past four months
but with with cases rising dramatically
not just here in Maricopa County but all
across the Arizona we wanted to be here
to get a report from the ground we take
back what we heard here today will
ensure with the team that we brought
with us including the Acting Secretary
of Homeland Security who oversees FEMA
to make sure that Arizona has what you
need when you need it I told the
governor today we say to the people of
Arizona work with you
we're going to make sure that Arizona
has whatever it takes to meet this
moment to slow the spread the threat
flatten the curve to save lives that's
our commitment and every one of you we
also brought along a Bianca love chick
who has a coordinated all of the PPE
supplies the construction of ventilators
while we are encouraged to hear today
that's the hospital capacity here
remains strong on supplies and equipment
we did here in the briefing today for
the need for personnel we've already
responded 62 medical personnel arrived
this week in Tucson but the governor
conveyed to us an additional request for
another 500 personnel and I've
instructed the Acting Secretary of
Homeland Security
to move out of me
providing additional doctors and nurses
and technical personnel we want to say
to all the incredible healthcare workers
here in Arizona help is on the way and
we're going to spare no expense to
provide the kind of reinforcements that
you will need all across this stage of
this this corona virus pandemic
continued to expand in Arizona as I said
we were encouraged to hear that hospital
capacity remains manageable at eighty
eight eighty five percent of medical
beds and only 88 percent of ICU beds but
the governor and I also spoke today
about two additional facilities that
were already reviewed and developed by
the Army Corps of engineer the governor
knows that we're prepared to stand those
search facilities up in very short order
if the need should arrive we're going to
make sure that
that Arizona continues to have the
healthcare capacity in this state to
render to everyone the contracts the
coronavirus the level of healthcare that
we would want anyone of our family
members to receive finally let me say
the President and I couldn't be more
grateful for Governor Ducey's leadership
throughout this coronavirus pandemic
with cases rising in the last several
week I'll make it clear that we fully
support the steps to Governor Doug Ducey
and local health officials are
implementing here across the state of
Arizona to slow the spread Arizona
flattened liquor early on in this
pandemic we all know that something
changed about the middle of May and
that's why this governor stepped forward
took decisive action put the health of
the people of Arizona first and
President Trump and I fully support the
responsible steps that he's taken the
lended large gatherings forepaws
operations of bars and gyms movie
theaters and water parks and delay the
start of school
August 17th President Trump and I and
our entire task force are absolutely
committed governor supporting your
efforts to respond to this outbreak slow
the spread to protect the most
vulnerable so that we can keep our
economy moving forward and get our kids
back to school
CDC just today the posted new guidance
for getting our kids back to school
yesterday posted new guidance for
opening up colleges and universities the
governor and I discussed today
the paramount importance of us moving
forward in a way where we can get our
kids back into the classroom it's been
that tremendous leadership here in
Arizona since the first days of this
pandemic your healthcare works it's done
a remarkable job particularly in recent
weeks that at this very hour caring for
those that have been impacted by the
but I want to say to all the good people
of Arizona we all need to do our part we
want to encourage every Arizona to
adhere to the guidance the governor has
issued and also the guidance of local
authorities we issue a particularly to
young people I was informed today by the
Maricopa County Department of Health
that more than 50% of all of those who
are testing positive in Maricopa County
are under the age of 35 young people
know that without an underlying health
condition that the threat to them of a
serious outcome for the corona virus
remains low but we want to remind our
young people as you see the measures
that the governor's put into place you
hear about the call for common-sense
personal hygiene and wearing a vest that
this is about protecting our most
vulnerable
I've got three 20-somethings in my
family and I know that no young person
here in Arizona would want to
inadvertently expose a grandmother or
grandfather an elderly neighbor a mom or
a dad to the coronavirus so each of them
we want to commend all the steps the
governor's put into place but we want to
remind you now is the time for all of us
particularly the young among us to
remember wash your hands practice good
hygiene wear a mask when indicated by
state or local authorities or when
social distancing is not possible
we can all do our part slow the spread
flatten the curve save life
remember it's not an either/or dr.
Pouncy said not just a few short days
ago that we shouldn't look at these
public safety measures as an impediment
to continuing to open up our economy we
should look at them as a vehicle to
opening up the more we all do and to
support the public health measures that
have put into effect the quicker we can
get it Arizona's economy growing get our
kids back to school and that's before
the trip we're all in this together and
together I'm very comfortable as all of
us do our part each and every day
will slow the spread flatten the girth
we'll save lives all across this state
and we will lay a foundation to bring
this state's economy back bigger and
better than ever
thank you very much governor Ducey thank
you for and
informative reason work with
I want to say Thank You mr. vice
president for your leadership and your
partnership throughout this pandemic it
was great to see you today in person but
I'm able to see you at least once or
twice a week on the constant
communication that we have from the
coronavirus task force
we very much appreciate it your
commitment and president's Trump's
commitment to serving Arizona and
helping us out the issues there in front
of us today I also want to thank the
coronavirus task force staff secretary
Chad Wolfe here today Rear Admiral of
Jack who was talking to us about
supplies and dr. deborah birx has been
with us for several days in Arizona
meeting with leaders decision makers and
influencers in the healthcare industry
across our state and actually seeing
what's happening across the southwest
including New Mexico and Texas we're
grateful for what she's been able to
contribute to the discussion the
questions she was able to answer and
guidance that she was able to clarify I
also want to thank general McGuire and
dr. Cara Crest for working with their
counterparts in the federal government
and the hard work that they have been
doing and most of all I want to say
thankful thank you to our health care
workers who are on the front lines our
doctors our nurses our hospital staff
all of our caregivers the decisions that
we are making are to help you help the
people in Arizona that need it so our
message is clear in terms of where
Arizona is today you are safer at home
we want to slow the spread of this virus
and protect the most vulnerable we have
taken the steps to temporarily close
bars and gyms and water parks tubing and
movie dinners we focused for a long time
and have done a very good job on our
most vulnerable those that are 65 years
or older and at high risk or with
chronic health issues
we now need the message to spread far
and wide that we all can contribute to
slowing the spread of this virus and
have Arizona a safer place by following
the fundamentals of masking up washing
your hands maintaining that physical
distance between others and when you're
sick staying home if we commit to that
and we do it with with increased
intensity over the next several weeks
we're going to be in a different and
better position in Arizona so with that
again I want to thank our federal
partners vice president pence and
president Trump whatever we have asked
for and
whether it was increased testing or
further support on contact tracing a
personal protective equipment from face
guards - Duke - gowns the answer has
been yes and with urgency in addition to
helping clarify some federal guidance
that will help our hospitals here on the
ground with support and resources so I
couldn't be more grateful for your
partnership and leadership in this
battle it's something we need to remain
vigilant and also have flexibility to
work with our local leaders across the
state move done an incredible job
communicating the benefits of putting on
a mask and how that can help our fellow
citizens slow the virus and protect the
most vulnerable and with that I want to
turn the podium over to secretary wolf
of Homeland Security who has been an
incredible partner as well on everything
that Arizona has needed not only with
the focus from FEMA
but whatever issues we had at the border
as well for that we're grateful
secretary wall
we first start off by again thanking the
vice president for his leadership of the
coronavirus task force and the team that
he's really put together several of
which are here today it's really been
outstanding let me also thank governor
ducey again your leadership throughout
the pandemic but particularly over the
last several weeks as you've seen cases
increase here and again for the team
that you pulled together as well DHS
continues to proudly support Arizona and
all the states that are continuing to
respond to the pandemic done so we've
obligated more than 90 million to the
state of Arizona for National Guard
operations for alternative care
facilities other emergency protective
measures and we'll continue to do that
we also say that again through Admiral
walk checks great efforts we've been
able to send over 318 million units of
PPE to the state of Arizona as well
continue to search as we need to do that
as well
governor mentioned the border we
continue to look at any threats that are
coming across the border and we put in
some essential restrictions several
months together to make sure that we
slowed the spread while keeping
essential traffic and that trade
occurring across your southern more our
southern border in Arizona southern
border absolutely critical to the
economies along that border in the US
we want to make sure that we get that
right we're continuing to assess that on
a day-by-day week-by-week basis to see
if there's any changes that we need to
make and then we'll certainly talk about
that at the taskforce let me just end by
again thanking the governor for his
efforts throughout the pandemic and I
will say as we deal with the pandemic
we're also dealing with other incidents
that are going on throughout the country
so the governor strong support for law
and order is vitally important in these
days as the department is the country's
largest law enforcement agency and so we
stand ready to support our state and
local partners as we're protecting
federal facilities we're protecting
monuments and statues and lights I want
to again thank the governor for his
outstanding work as well
mr. vice president Governor Ducey has
been a privilege to be with the people
of Arizona for the last two or three
days what has been remarkable to me is
watching the people of Arizona respond
to the bass cup Arizona
guidelines that made it clear that we
respect one another by wearing masks I
saw that wherever I went for the last
several days in Maricopa County and I
want to thank the people of Arizona for
showing that respect for each other
we know this virus is circulating
actively in several counties we also
know that there are other counties at
risk and I want to call on all the
county leadership
and the individuals in each of these
counties that as soon as you see an
increase in your test positivity rate to
put on a mask protect one another
governor Ducey's directives to really
increase our red not only of respect for
one another but that clear communication
coming from his health team that they
did clear that wearing a mask will
change the threat of this virus and also
making it clear that this moment in time
closing the bars decreasing restaurant
spaces and the other actions will really
dramatically have an impact to all of
our Millennials and Gen C thank you
thank you for your leadership and
showing how important the mask and
social distancing are and that
communication that you're having with
your parents and your grandparents to
protect them I also want to call on you
to be aware that there are people in
your age group
people in your age group every day that
have pre-existing condition conditions
that you may not know about and they
have diabetes and they have hypertension
that they have a weight issue these
individuals no matter what their age are
susceptible and you can see it in the
hospitalizations here in Arizona so
you're not only protecting those we
totally respect to the over 65 age group
or you're protecting one another and I
appreciate that yesterday I got to meet
with an entire group and it showed the
governor's commitment and the health
commitment of doctor Chris to
understanding guidelines don't work
unless they're translated and working
alongside community members so in that
meeting for community members from the
Hispanic community from the
african-american community and today I
got to be with the tribal nations
leaders understanding that messages are
not a standalone that they have to
translate into the very fabric of our
communities so that people understand
what their risks are so the people can
get tested and so that people understand
the importance of wearing a mask
I also saw incredible innovation of the
American spirit we heard from your
universities and we heard from your
hospitals the advances that you're
taking into the field and care for those
who need us the most
coming out at our universities to
provide innovations and testing and
really expanding testing we talked about
how to 10x testing through pooling and
communities communities that are in
multi-generational households bringing
testing to the community into those
households and using household pools to
be able tested under percent of the
community I want to thank the
african-american leader I met yesterday
from the community who set up an African
American task force to really make sure
that messages from the governor and the
help team were being translated at the
level of the people who needed to hear
it
I thank you for bringing together an
understanding that words that are
translated into action will not stop
this virus but I am encouraged and I'm
hopeful and I think we will see the
dramatic impact of you are taking
responsibility and wearing masks so when
it comes to August we can hope in the
schools and open the universities
because
we can stop the spread by utilizing gas
and making these in small adjustments
into our lifestyle the show respect for
one another
so thank you governor Ducey for your
leadership when you're looking at the
science and the data and the evidence
thank you for your health team at the
brilliant dr. chris has been a pleasure
to spend time with you and your amazing
County public health leaders who
understand how to get into the community
thank you for your time and their
respect that you gave me by wearing mass
and public thank you
yes please
we received a request in the last 24
hours from the state of Arizona for
roughly an additional 500 additional
personnel
we'll be moving out on that very quickly
one of the one of the aspects of our
nation's response over the last four
months is finished ordinary efforts
with our medical personnel but president
truck
whether it be New York whether people in
Siena weather
in our house
actually deployed active duty
military medical personality so the
secretary and I will be speaking on Air
Force two
with the leadership at FEMA to identify
personnel that are available but they'll
be packing up and moving out
here in Arizona to know that help is on
detailing that to the felt
well let let me say that our objective
would be that that would ever happen in
Arizona or anywhere else in the United
States or America
we're out
our nation's respond
the corona virus pandemic very early on
the prison's direction not only did we
reinvent testing now more than 33
million tests before
the nearly 600,000 tests a day or make
in the area personal protective
equipment
ventilators
the president marshal the whole of
America response
with the strong leadership of applejohn
collection
we've made sure the states have point of
the knee
there it was this verse manifested in
Washington or whether it happened in the
Greater New York City area New Jersey
Connecticut Louisiana Michigan we made
sure that health care workers in all of
those areas that were impacted by rising
coronavirus cases in this pandemic
personal protective equipment and just
as importantly ventilators necessary
that they would never have to make a
choice
between rendering care to one American
versus not rendering care to another at
this point the adverb logic told me
today that we started this pandemic with
roughly 15,000 ventilators in the
national stockpile very soon we will
have nearly 50,000 ventilators and as I
stand here today
no American who's required a ventilator
has ever been denied a ventilator in the
United States of America
we delivered ventilators at the
governor's request some time ago and
as I sure the governor today he's going
to have whatever in heat whatever it
takes
it's ventilators it's more personal
have it but the report we received today
was in hospitals across Arizona
have capacity the personal protective
equipment we've been checking down on a
hospital by hospital basis we're gonna
make sure that happens we're gonna fix
you're ever in Arizona impacted by the
grow devices and fire us against them to
healthcare that we even want any member
of our family to have
yes please
one of the ways the president marshal
the whole of America approaches we
brought in all of the pharmaceutical
company
in America which are the greatest in the
world early on in this pandemic and we
challenge them
we challenge have not only to develop
vaccines
which are being developed and researched
at a record pace but also the
development of what are called
therapeutics or to a lay person like me
it's the medicines that make you feel
better governor this week we were able
to inform it will receive another round
of rim disappear we've been able to
acquire that from Gilead and distribute
that in all 50 states it's been having
very positive effect on helping people
recover from the corona virus the advent
of the steroid treatment that has been
utilized to good effect helping people
to recover
and of course the convalescent plasma
where people over a million Americans
have fully
cover from the coronavirus and I would I
would renew our ongoing request anyone
in Arizona said the corona virus
fully recovered contact your local Red
Cross donate blood so that you could be
a part of providing that was called
convalescent plasma the people who were
also seeing promising results
but on the subject of vaccines I want to
assure you the president initiated
operation warp speed we put a team in
place that's that's working now with the
better part of a half a dozen very
promising vaccine
development we remain hopeful that even
before the end of this year I have a
vaccine available
there'll be no compromising on the
safety of a vaccine
to go through the process but the
presidents made it very clear that we're
not going to wait to produce vaccines
until we go through all of the different
clinical trials that are difficult
we have promising results which we do on
several vaccines today we're going to
produce those vaccines in the event that
when the clinical trials are completed
as early as this fall we might be able
to distribute that Navajo check for his
part told me that we're also acquiring
hundreds of millions of syringes
the American people can be confident
we're working every day to develop new
therapeutics to develop those vaccines
but we're always going to make sure that
everything was sure
it's safe
absolutely our determination is that
and as another one of our health
professionals said there even our
scientists say from the early results
it's not the evidence when we have a
vaccine but when we have a vaccine
we'll make sure it's safe for the
American people yes please
well the rising cases here in Arizona is
why I'm here
that's why we brought the White House
corner by recessed force heater a real
believer as president Trump is sitting
down with people that are leading the
effort in Texas over the weekend I'll be
in Florida tomorrow because we're
absolutely determined to make sure that
Arizona and those health care workers
have the resources the supplies and the
equipment they need to render the care
that any one of us would want a member
of a family to have and I must tell you
today I I can't account for the reports
that you say the reality is that for the
briefing that we were seeing today
hospital capacity remains within
manageable lines an 85% of hospital beds
are spoken for eighty eight percent of
ICU beds have spoken we continue to see
cases rising but as we surveyed
hospitals across the state personal
protective equipment
render care appear to be an abundant
supply we're here to make sure that
remains to be the case we don't ever
want any health care professional making
a decision about who gets health care
who doesn't this is America we're going
to make sure
workers here in Arizona have the
equipment have the supplies and also
have the therapeutic medicines to render
care to save lives
that's our ongoing yes please
what's the concern I didn't hear it
well what I would tell people is that
when the president tapped me to leave
the White House coronavirus task force
we had one mission
that was a save life
and at the end of the 45 days to slow
the spread our mission adjustment that
was stabilized and open up America again
we've been working at every step of the
way but I I must tell you I don't I
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
the coronavirus relevant politics I
think about
people printed in fact of President
Trump before the end of January
suspended all travel from China stood up
the White House coronavirus task force
that we that we've marshal not only the
full resources of the federal government
but the full resources of the American
economy the scale testing at an
unprecedented level the United States
now is tested more than 33 million
people that that we've literally seems
in a distribution of billions of
supplies to healthcare workers and
hospitals around the country we've seen
the development of will at a fluid
constructed 110,000 ventilators
in a hundred days to make sure those are
available for healthcare workers all
across this country
in the development of therapeutics and
medicines even while we're continuing in
across this country to find ways to
safely and responsibly reopen I think
I think the American people understand
this is an unprecedented moment the
president Trump has brought
unprecedented leadership and we've
spared no expense we pulled together all
the resources in this nation that we're
going to continue to do that every
single day until that day comes though
we put the coronavirus in the past about
about one more unless you get it
no I was never briefed about that matter
and I'm not going to discuss classified
materials
but I will tell you having served
alongside mr. president three and a half
years and also being the father of the
United States Marine and the
father-in-law of a sailor I couldn't be
more proud of this president's ongoing
efforts to support our military whether
it be historic increases in military
spending or whether it be the decisive
action this president took to take out
the leader of Isis take out the Iranian
general Soleimani president Trump has
never hesitated to take action
to protect the lives of American
soldiers sailors airmen and Marines and
he never will
about one more on top go
I can't I can't
I can't hear ya very sorry
but over here
you step forward a little bit
well the reason we're here is because of
the rising number of cases in Arizona as
well as the rising positivity
it's very clear we have community spread
in this state and across much of the Sun
though that's the reason why we we
wanted to be here to receive a briefing
you see but it's also why we wanted to
be here to express our strong support
steps that Governor Ducey and then local
officials that put into effect limiting
certain gatherings closing certain
establishments during this rising time
we have every confidence the governor's
leadership
and local health officials across the
state
Arizonans are going to be able to do
what you did before you're going to be
able to slow the spread and plant the
curve our objective is is to make sure
that the governor has everything that he
needs to make this moment provide the
level of health care that every one of
our families would want but certainly
it's simply to call on the people of
Arizona
we all have a role player we are all in
this together and recognizing that
adhering to the guidance of state local
officials
practicing good hygiene washing their
hands wearing a mask when it's indicated
or when social distancing is not
possible as how every single person can
do their part and we really do believe
that that just as Arizona did in the
early days of this pandemic that the
people of Arizona
once again leave the way through this
rising tide i'm coronavirus cases
we're gonna move this state forward get
this economy moving
and we're gonna get our kids back to
school that's our a little VR focus
I want to thank the governor again and
this extraordinary team
they're their leadership in their
partnership we're with you or something
we're going to stay with you every day
until that day when we put the
coronavirus so thank you all god bless
you
I
you